for the first time a government agency
in the u.s. is suing Facebook over its
alleged failure to protect users
personal information the Attorney
General of Washington DC started
investigating Facebook earlier this year
the probe began after the company
allowed the political consulting firm
Cambridge analytical to obtain user data
wired editor in chief and CBS News
contributor Nicholas Thompson shows us
the potential risks for Facebook Nick
good morning good morning the story this
the lawsuit comes days after a scathing
New York Times report on the ways that
Facebook share data with its more than
150 corporate partners Facebook has been
on the defensive for months now as
consumers question the company's
commitment to protecting their privacy
I think this lawsuit will accelerate a
change in a lawsuit filed Wednesday
District of Columbia attorney general
Karl Racine alleges Facebook
misrepresented the extent to which it
protects its consumers personal data and
failed to adequately disclosed to
consumers that their data can be
accessed without their knowledge users
you know in many many cases had no idea
how their personal and user information
was being utilized in a statement
facebook says we're reviewing the
complaint and look forward to continuing
our discussions with attorneys general
in DC and elsewhere
it was my mistake and I'm sorry since
the Cambridge analytical scandal
Facebook has faced growing criticism for
a series of privacy missteps last week
the company admitted that nearly 7
million users photos may have been
exposed to third party apps and on
Tuesday the New York Times reported that
the company gave many tech companies far
greater access to user data than
previously had been disclosed some
including Netflix and Spotify were
allowed to read write and delete users
private messages through services they
built but on Wednesday Facebook said the
data was only available to those
companies when users accessed their apps
using a facebook login quote no third
party was reading your private messages
or writing messages to your friends
without your permission
I just can't kind of tolerate the lack
of respect of me as a user that we see
from Facebook Terral and mcCormick
is marking her 10-year anniversary as a
Facebook user by breaking up with the
social media platform for good
she's one of many cutting back a survey
in January found 74 percent of Facebook
users said they logged on daily but by
June 42% reported that they were taking
a break of a few weeks or more 26
percent said they deleted the app from
their phones we trust that a company is
going to protect our privacy protect our
data and I think we've seen from
Facebook in the last few years that
they're just not doing that Facebook
stock dropped more than seven percent
yesterday according to the Attorney
General his office had discussions with
a number of other states that are
interested in protecting personal
information seems like it just keeps
heating up for Facebook now let me ask
about this facebook says that users gave
their permission to share this data is
that true users gave their permission
they logged in to the places to the
corporate partners but I don't think
users quite understood entirely how
their data was being shared
so can Facebook protect our privacy and
still grow their business or is the
business model and sharing this data
irrevocably bound together that is the
foundational question for Facebook the
central problem is that for most of
their lifetime they prioritized growth
and utility and not privacy and that is
coming back to bite them this comes as a
damming time with that Senate report
saying they weren't as forthcoming as
many investigators I hope they would be
well and that so many people are
manipulating Facebook and other social
media to undermine democracy and
continue to do so absolutely Nick thank
you great to have you thank you home